- Hey, I'm Daniel Kaluuya
and this is how I became
Chairman Fred Hampton.
(soft music)
- Deputy Chairman Fred Hampton
of the Illinois Black Panther Party.
- Well, it means that the young Patriots,
you know what the Confederate flag?
That scene?
That was the first day
and I was really nervous.
And I think it was something
that wasn't working,
the scene wasn't working and then
we managed to figure out
why it wasn't working.
I think it was the first
time I'd done the voice
and had everything in
a scene, like halfway
through the scene and
then it was just like.
We'll be okay, 'cause I think I tapped,
I think that day was me
shedding the iconness of him.
And I actually was really embodying him.
And, but I had to just kind
of wear it for like half a day
in order to feel it and
then go, oh yeah, this fits!
Let's go.
You know what I'm saying?
And, and so that's for
me, it was like halfway
through the first day when I realized,
I was like, oh I'm playing a man.
Who has a goal and loves
this group of people.
- [Man] I will learn all I can.
[Audience] I will learn all I can.
- [Man] In order to give my best to my
people in the struggle for liberation.
- It was a tipping point when,
when I went to Chicago,
when I went by myself
to Chicago for like a week,
that was the tipping point.
I wouldn't call it more
important than anything else
'cause I think everything is as important
even as the small details.
But it was a tipping
point in terms of like,
"Cool I feel I'm in here,"
do you understand?
But I think it was just
like, I needed to get
into that space and just
completely focus on it
for a week in order to
understand like, yeah,
I can hit, I can sit in a certain position
and be a vessel that I'm aspiring to be.
- [Man] You can murder a freedom fighter,
but you can't murder freedom!
- Usually in other processes
I would have a collection of people,
that I was like, this is the area
that I would like a bit
of this and a bit of that.
So I would just listen to people
that I felt like I wanted
to have a vibe of this.
I want to have this vibe and I want to go
into that direction.
And with this, I looked for
people that sounded similar
to Chairman Fred, and
just there wasn't much.
He's got a very distinct way of speaking.
And I just had to focus on him, you know?
But, yeah, what that
gifted me was a new way
of approaching things was that,
Oh, I need to really get into-
if speech is a window into how you think-
I need to get into his thinking
in order to move in the
space of his speech.
And so I was like, Oh, okay cool.
Like, why does this river make sense?
Why am I saying this word?
How are the new thoughts igniting
from the thought before, you know?
Igniting in a different way,
which is why you're speaking
in that way which is why
it's like you see that
in the classroom scene.
For me it was like
"tidididiba tidididiba."
He just goes "doosh," he goes "doosh."
But he can take his time.
But then the turn is "Bow!"
Do you understand?
And that's what's quite thrilling
about the way he speaks.
I saw that from watching him.
It's like, Oh, it's like
this, this, this, this, this
and boom!
This, this, this, this,
this, this, then boom!
Another direction.
This, this, this, this, then boom!
And I'm like, no one
can even see that turn.
So I need to process those thoughts
in that ways, in order
to replicate the river.
- Imagine what we could
accomplish together.
We can heal this whole city.
- I think that's the
alarming thing I found
about Chairman Fred.
There was no comparison.
There was no touchstone
that I could kind of go,
Oh, I get it.
It was like, when I read the script,
I said this is brand new.
This is like I have never seen.
What the hell is happening here?
I remember Shaka had
two touchstones that he
kind of thought of that helped me
access the voice actually,
which was Bernie Mac,
and then he mentioned Richard Pryor.
It's not something that
I had internalized,
but he was just saying
the command that they had
over an audience was similar.
And I think they're both Illinois.
Yeah, they're both from Chicago.
And Richard Pryor was definitely that era,
so I know I found old-school
Richard Pryor tapes.
And I was listening to that to find
if there was anything that
would feed what was building.
When I was in Chicago, I figured out
I don't want any specific ones,
but the ones from 1968, 69
were like, you can't find them.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So I know I want that,
but then it didn't feed me
in that way.
But, I think knowing that he listened
to Malcolm X and listened
to Martin Luther King
in the movie and in his regular day
in order to build his oratorial abilities
gave me a window into
his thinking even more.
But I wouldn't compare him
to Martin Luther King or Malcolm X.
He kind of absorbed those ideas
and created something new.
That's the genius of him.
He absorbed all these ideas
and created something original.
Like, original thoughts
in an original way.
You know what I'm saying?
That it hasn't been seen again
in the public domain,
you know what I'm saying?
That was probably the biggest mountain.
It was like, I had no
touchstone, it was no one.
I was like, Oh, this is like this.
And this is like that.
I've said before like
the widow's character,
I saw it as a beady seagull.
You know what I'm saying?
So I was like, "boom!"
All right, cool.
I see, I know that.
I know that way.
I know a couple of guys, I grew up with,
you know what I'm saying?
And so like I knew the world.
I knew the mentality in that sense.
I knew the decision-making,
this is incomparable.
- [Man] I am
- [Audience] I am
- [Man] A revolutionary!
- [Audience] A revolutionary!
- [Man] I am
- [Audience] I am
- [Man] A revolutionary!
- [Audience] A revolutionary!
- [Man] I am
- [Audience] I am
- [Man] A revolutionary!
(drumming music)
- [Audience] A revolutionary!
- I think it was Shaka, Lucas brothers'
and Will Burson's decision
to make it a genre piece.
Thus making it accessible
for prime viewers
and thriller watches.
And, you know, in that sense,
cause it's kind of like
a similar narrative
to Donnie Brasco, or The
Departed, or you know
those kinds of films and so in that sense
if someone loves that sort of narrative
they're going to be drawn upon it
and then meet this
world and these politics
and these views and these perspectives
and Chairman Fred Hampton, you know?
So that, for me, is what separates it, is
that as a genre piece, I
mean, a genre as opposed to
just about it being about educating
and informing about the Black
Panther Party, it's like,
what did Ryan and Shaka say?
You put the medicine in the food.
Is how they saw it.
- [Man] When I dedicated
my life to people,
I dedicated my life.
- I think it was the 50
year anniversary that day.
We did a poison in that scene.
And then the scene where
Chairman Fred makes a certain decision.
And I found that day
personally really awful.
To find the truth, get out of my own way.
My emotions were flaring up.
You understand?
So, I wasn't clear.
I realized how entangled
and meshed I was to this.
And I really felt some real things.
And it was kind of like stopping
me from accessing the truth
and the way I usually access it.
And so it was more of that.
It was that I found
that really challenging
to find the way in the way
that I usually find it.
- [Man] Anywhere there's
people, there's power.
- I think Shaka said it today, he said
what O'Neil isn't shows
you what Chairman Fred is.
I think it was, he says
it way more articulate
than that, I just said it.
I'm going to text him after and ask him
for a specific quote.
But, yeah, so I think it's that.
It's like you can't appreciate
the light without the dark.
That's just life.
That's just truth.
That's law.
So I think we were both in
service of Chairman Fred
is the reality, you know,
and then I've heard the Keef
articulate that for himself
in order to access what's
in places that he had to go to.
So, yeah, I think we just
kind of sat in that truth
and supported each other on
days that we needed support
when certain days where
he had to do some really
intense stuff.
I was there, yo what'd you need?
And one of those days where
I needed to do intense stuff
he was there like, yeah,
yeah, what do you need?
So it kind of moved like that.
- The Black Panthers are
forming a Rainbow Coalition
of oppressed brothers and
sisters of every color.
(steady music)